Now, what about your success rates that you're having at the clinic? How many patients are you
seeing? Are they coming in pre chemo, post surgery, post chemo? Give me a kind of snapshot of
the people that you're seeing and what kind of results that you're having in your clinic compared
to the kind of alopathic Western medicine approach to cancer treatments? That's probably the most
common question that we get when people call our office. What's your success rate? Being an alternative
clinic that sees people with cancer, we have to be very careful with our language. So we do not
say that we treat cancer. From a medical legal standpoint, I believe you have to be an oncologist
to treat cancer. So we treat patients who have all sorts of diseases. Now, we specialize in people
that have a disease called cancer, our success rate. So let's take a step back how medical
profession measures the success rate with cancer is after their diagnosis, how many of these people
with this exact type of cancer post diagnosis are still alive after five years. They could die one
day after five years and they would still be listed as cured. See, they could live a horrific life
for five years and they die one day after five years and they're still listed as we cured that person.
Oh, wow. Even if the cause of death was that disease. Yes. So it's a little skewed at you. So you get a lot
of rubber numbers out there with the success rate of cancer. The only honest way to measure success
rate of cancer is quality of life. And for one aspect, I do not believe anybody's ever cured of cancer.
Now, people will argue with me with that. No, God cured me. I don't have any cancer in my body.
But that may be true. I do believe we're a spiritual clinic. We believe that God is your only healer.
But we also believe that God can do anything He wants to do. But we also believe that you always have
cancer cells. Even if you don't have... Right, you just talked about this earlier, right? Exactly.
Even if I don't have a diagnosis of cancer, I have cancer cells. So you have to always be treated as if.
And assuming that I do have that and constantly, you never quit. So when we use the knife,
all of our patients go home with the knife, for instance. And people will ask, when can I stop using that?
And the answer is never. You know, you're going to use that the rest of your life.
The same thing with, when can I stop not eating junk food? Right. The answer is never.
Never. Doesn't mean you can, you know, you have to use the knife every single day. And it doesn't
mean you have to eat a perfect diet your rest of your life. You can cheat and you can still enjoy
life at times. But your, your sway of your lifestyle has to be tweaked. And you want to keep it that way.
So that's the number one perspective. And as far as success rates, when we measure our success rates
with most of our patients come to us. I'd say probably about 70% right now come to us. They've already
done chemo surgery or radiation or some combination thereof. And the Zen they seek places like us out.
It just is what it is. Because most people, they hear, you know, they get a diagnosis of cancer,
they're in shock. And they typically don't think, you know, when the college say, you have breast cancer,
their first thought is like, huh, I got to go home and research this and how I can take care of it.
They just want someone to tell them what to do. That's right. And it is our human inclination to not
want to take responsibility. I want the doctor to fix me. So it's real easy to like give your
power over to somebody else who's going to, who's going to take care of it. Right. It's comforting.
It's very comforting. It is. And it takes a lot of pressure off of us. But it's also very dangerous.
So we try to re-empower people in our practice that you need to be your advocate. We're here to
educate you. We're here to help you. We're here to come along side you. But we're not here to take
the responsibility away from you. That would be disempowering. And that would be, that wouldn't be helpful
for you. So again, most of our patients come to us that have already gone down the medical route.
And the reason why they're coming to us is that it wasn't as successful as they wanted it to be.
So a good percentage of those people are already given a time frame. Maybe we've had people with
given two weeks. We live near Mayo here. So a lot of people come from Mayo. They've been given two
weeks or six months to live. And they're in dire strides. So part of, I believe, our responsibility
is to re-enstill hope that they don't have to listen to that. That no one knows their time
when their time is to go. They have to be, I'm big enough to be in a realist, but it's very important
to not let even the statistics that are out there to govern your life and to create fear.
You have to believe that that God has a purpose for you and that that your time is in his hands.
And that there's ways to deal with this other than the medical profession that's out there. So those
are, or that's, that's a big part of our patients. I wish we had more like the 20 to 30 percent where
they come to us. They had a phone on a have cancer. I want to do a natural approach as well. Or you
start with a natural approach and only do the chemo radiation surgery if I have to. My training is
an integrative care. So I'm not against standards of care. I'm just against maybe gross uses of it.
There's can be benefits to chemo and radiation and surgery in certain types of cancer. But it might
not be, we might not want to use the big guns first. So if we could do more things from a natural
perspective and change the person's lifestyle, I think we get better results. So our success rate is
really based upon what you have a person that's, you know, we the 27 years of doing this. We see,
we've seen people that have been given just weeks to months to live and they live years later.
I mean, that is a success. So and even if they still only live six months,
that their quality of life was so much better than being sick and ill and throwing up and
just they can't enjoy their family and their grandkids, there just doesn't seem to be a lot of
benefits to that either.